when I'm going to teach my daughter
something I get down on eye level with
her
because I am humongous compared to her
little body and when I hover over and
say hey her body instantly goes to fight
or flight there is no more learning
happening there
she'll do what I say because I'm
humongous she will not learn why we're
doing what we're doing
so I'll get down and I'll look her in
the eye and say hey
and I'll hold both of her hands if
she'll do that sometimes she will
sometimes she won't and I will say
listen if you put this in that light
socket you will die
yeah don't do that and she'll get real
wide-eyed and I'll say I love you and my
job is to keep you safe right see I'm
teaching her in that moment